- [Gary] What if I told you this
was the last Monday
morning of your life?
What if I told
you died this week?
Would you complain about your
crap job or that test you don't
want to take?
I doubt it.
You'd go to much
higher level thinking.
We cram a ton of
all-time shit into this day.
I was on a fuckin'--
- [DRock] There was a lot today.
(upbeat music)
- Aren't we doing
the barbaresco?
Also, let's start promoting one
of those Cinderella clearance
sales 'cause we need
to clear that out.
So is that entrance is open?
If you come from the High Line?
As you leave, you can walk
to the High Line? That's cool.
Morning.
Do I have a lot of
time in Orlando?
Am I there like the night--
- You land, I think
you land at midnight.
- [Gary] Okay.
- You have the night to sleep
and to workout and
an hour on stage and
then you'll leave at 12:30.
- So we're gonna go with no.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Woman] Very
different from my office.
Good to see you.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
How's your office?
- [Woman] Um, it's great.
The views are amazing.
- I know. The views
are crazy here, right?
- [Woman] Yeah.
I was noticing the differences
between our space and yours.
Next time we'll have to have
the meeting with Frédéric.
- Yeah, just for him to see it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Okay.
Hey.
- [Nate] Hey.
How's it going?
- Good, you sent me a
(censored) so I can sell it.
- [Nate] Yeah.
(censored).
- The same thing
we did last time?
- [Nate] Pretty much,
you're comfortable with that.
- [Gary] How much did we
charge and how much did we do?
- [Nate] Our fee for the media
spend was (censored) if they
paid us for all our
efforts into it (censored).
So a difference (censored).
- Okay.
So this girl in Arizona,
Little Lou and you?
- [Nate] Me,
Little Lou, Phil, AJ.
- [Gary] What a crew.
- [Nate] And Ally.
- [Gary] Oh Ally,
the Patriot fan?
- [Nate] She might
come to the game.
- [Gary] She really?
- [Nate] That's what AJ said.
- [Gary] Where you guys sittin'?
- [Nate] Visitor side,
50 yard line.
- [Gary] Nice. Love it.
Proper.
- [Tyler] Believe he
traveled here from Paris.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [DRock] Really?
- Yeah, he just
had emailed Gary,
I pulled him out and figured.
- [DRock] Just for a selfie?
- [Gary] Not from
Paris for a selfie.
- [DRock] I don't know.
- His opening line, I'm from
Paris across the ocean to spend
two weeks in
New York City just to meet you.
Yesterday I waited
over three hours
in the lobby of Hudson Yards.
- [Man] 'Sup Gary?
- [Gary] How are you?
- Real pleasure.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- Wow, that's something.
Hey. This is DRock?
- [Gary] This is DRock.
- [DRock] How are you?
- [Man] Hi, nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are things?
- Great, great.
- Good.
- I have something to tell you.
- Okay.
- Can we do it right there?
- Sure.
- [Man] Is that okay?
Do we really have
three minutes or--
- [Gary] I have two minutes.
Yeah.
- [Man] Oh. Okay.
- [Gary] Yeah, I have to run to
a thing but maybe
three or four minutes.
- [Man] Okay.
There's two parts,
first what it is.
We saw the (inaudible)
marketing platforms.
They were too expensive.
It's almost
advertising agencies--
- Yep.
- But with some
profiles you can scroll.
- Of course.
- It's for big brands.
- Yes.
- Logos--
- Yeah, of course.
- So we're like
we're gonna break
this 'cause it's a pattern.
The guys who make the big
bucks, except Facebook.
- Two minutes?
- [Man] Okay.
We did this and then I went to
New York and Montreal and Paris
and basically the marketing
agencies say go fuck yourself.
- So you're trying to figure out
how to get me to be an investor
or be involved?
- I'm doing, you
know, Facebook ads.
- Yeah.
- I'm dong the best
targeting I could do.
- Yeah.
- Word of mouth guy.
When I read your book.
- Yeah.
- The full
chapter on what I do--
- Yeah.
- I was like I have to go.
For a year I was
watching your videos--
- Yep.
- I was like he talks
about this all the time.
- Yes.
- And I bought the
book a month ago--
- Yes.
- And I was long tail,--
- Let's go, walk with me.
- [Man] Summary for you.
- Are you a developer per se
or are you the
architect of the product?
- No, my partner is a developer.
Basically, he goes you
tell me what to do--
- And I'll build it.
- Yeah.
I know everybody's telling you
hey I'm gonna grind for you,
I don't want to tell
you this 'cause--
- [Gary] I hear it every day.
- That's not what I do.
- [Gary] Yeah, I understand.
So, are you gonna
be able to build it?
Are you just gonna build it?
Ty? Tyler?
Are you gonna be
able to build it now?
- What you mean build it?
- Like, you and your partner are
going to be able to build it?
- [Man] It's already existing.
- I'll take a look.
- The thing is we were
very arrogant and we went
all the kind of advertising--
- Go ahead.
- [Man] I was like we
have to niche this.
- [Gary] I see. I see.
I'll send you an email.
This weekend.
Good luck.
Did we tell him
where we're going?
- [DRock] Yeah.
45th and 5th.
- 4-5?
- [DRock] Yep. 4-5-5.
("Who Do I Work For" by
MatMusicPage)
- Hello, my friend, how are you?
Really good, my friend.
Really good.
Quick thing,
we run a media site,
VaynerMedia does for
(censored) called
(censored), right?
And it's going well and
we really want to
make a 2017 version of it.
Listen, by the way,
I'm not against it.
I don't have enough of a plan
that I have to have that I would
stop you from it.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
That I have to
really think about.
Flags and said man we're
about to be hiring in London.
@EricFulwiler get ready.
I think I put him in a tough
spot which is created some
context that would make
you trepidatious and others.
You coming? Yeah.
- [Mark] 30th and 10th,
Hudson Yards.
- [Gary] When you're playing a
different game, we have so many
benefits going in our favor
but we have to respect playing a
different game when it's
not going in our favor.
- [Mark] Exactly.
- People don't get it.
I will give up short-term
for long-term every time.
- We played a different game
and that's why we win so much.
And this is part of that.
This is a facet of that.
- 100, it's the
hardest facet of it.
- Oh, absolutely.
- It's super fun to be
egotistical and awesome but when
you're deploying
humility it's not as fun.
- Yes, I was gonna say.
Well there's a great line that
I think my eighth grade bus
driver said to me once.
(Gary and DRock laughing)
He said, he goes,
"You got to know
when to kick ass, you got to
know when to kiss ass," and
I was like you know what that
really and it stuck with me.
- That's interesting.
- And it harder, the kiss ass
part is harder but you know.
- It's way harder.
'Sup, brother?
How you been?
- How you doing?
- [Gary] Have you been
playing ball at all?
- No, I haven't
balled in a while.
- [Gary] I haven't
balled in a long time either.
- They still doing it at the Y?
- Yeah, I've just been
stretching so much but I want to
get back into it.
- Yeah, I need to
- Dude, get back into it.
- Let's do it.
- Put yourself on
GroupMe, alright?
Yeah, good stuff.
I'll talk to you soon.
- [Mark] Absolutely.
- [Gary] Did you see my email?
- About?
- I sent it yesterday.
The Teaberry font,
I love it on the back and
on the front--
- You want that on the front?
- I do. I like it way better.
'Cause at one point you had it
that way and then it
switched, right?
- [Zak] Yeah.
- [Gary] 'Sup, Greg?
Yeah, if you don't mind.
I really do like it.
Hey guys.
Where were you?
Hello.
On your Instagram you were
like you looked like you were at
Burning Man but you weren't.
Where were you?
- Miami.
- It's gonna be a fun one.
What?
How are you? Morning.
How are you?
Good.
Kitchen's become like
a really good place.
- [DRock] It'd be cool to
do a meeting in here.
- What?
- [DRock] A meeting in here.
- Yeah, I think you're right.
It's really great.
How you doing?
- Good.
- [Gary] Good week?
What?
- [Andy] Do you
have the cohost?
- What?
- [Andy] On the Facebook
page I'm doing an #AskGaryVee.
You can pick the five questions
you want to answer or the cohost
could pick the five or not.
- Yeah, cohost can do it.
Today, you mean?
- [Andy] Yes.
- Have Jake pick 'em?
- [Andy] On the Facebook page.
We're doing the
#AskGaryVee at 3:30,
ask your questions in
the comments.
- Okay, yeah.
Let Jake pick 'em.
Is that a new row already?
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] (laughs)
That didn't take long.
Shit is real already.
What?
Can you show me the back?
That.
- Or do you want--
- That.
Yeah, really like
the way that looked.
- So just--
- [Gary] They may not make it.
- Yeah. I'm not sure.
They had this address.
- [Gary] They know that.
- [Tyler] It's tight.
- Yep.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- [Gary] How did, she's here?
How did the mix up happen?
- (censored).
- [Gary] Yeah.
Who created the invite?
- Hudson Street and I just...
- [Gary] That's fine.
- I just fucked up.
- [Gary] That's comfortable.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That has logic.
Yeah, I don't want you to ever
do that again but at least it's
Hudson Street not like,
you know what I mean.
At least I can see
how your eye did that.
- So that's that.
- [Gary] My sister is gonna
shit when she sees this wine.
Here's why 'cause it, we
grew up on Teaberry Lane.
53 Teaberry Lane and my sister's
whole life is like revolves
around the nostalgia.
I didn't know I had it so
good with you and I should of...
(laughs).
- This is gorgeous.
- Thank you.
- [Hollis] This
is unbelievable.
- Crazy, right?
- [Hollis] I'm like
we're slumming it downtown.
Gary, this is just--
- Crazy, right?
- And you have 500 people here?
- I actually think
there's 600 here.
I'm gonna open up 5 or 6
offices in smaller city markets.
The reason I'm building
VaynerMedia is because I'm going
to buy businesses like my
clients and then run them
through this machine and if
I buy something that sells at
Dollar General and Walmart
I love the fact that I'll have
DNA in Des Moines.
Listen, you know me probably
pretty well from a business
standpoint, I'm so long-term.
- [Hollis] Yeah.
- I'm such a weird guy
for people 'cause I'm so--
- [Hollis] Sure.
- I'm so high-energy that it
feels but I'm so long-term.
- [Hollis] So the long game
is you want to be in
a product business.
- [Gary] The long-term is
I want to buy the Jets.
- [Hollis] I know that.
- I know you know and so my
belief is that the way I'm gonna
do it is by buying
(censored) for $113 million,--
- [Hollis] And then
doing it through--
- our way,--
- [Hollis] Yeah.
- and then selling it for 780.
- [Hollis] Right.
Those heritage brands?
- Yes.
I think nostalgia
is underpriced.
And then I want to talk about
whatever you want to talk about.
So Crushed It if I was to
subtitle it now I would say how,
you know, the sentence would
read
somewhere to the degree of like
how these 97
people read "Crush It!"
and crushed it and
how you can too.
Got it?
- [Hollis] Yeah.
- 'Cause I think, you
see where I am going?
I like the, visually in my mind
I like the idea like the word
crush it being green like
I don't know from a design
standpoint but that's really
cool.
That's A, kind of clever because
you might have a scenario where
people you could
sell the first book in
a weird way but
this is absolutely.
- [Hollis] We want to
talk about repackaging.
- Okay.
This can be a very thick
book, here's why I,
if I was to rewrite "Crush It!"
which is what I plan on doing,
personal brand has happened like
what I wrote
about in "Crush It!" transpired.
So, A, there's a lot
more to talk about.
I'm basically, no kidding,
rewriting at some level.
- [Hollis] Right.
- Meaning like okay
it's 2018, what do you do?
It's a phone first world.
It used to be a TV first world.
Pinterest and
Snapchat and Instagram
these are the ABC, NBCs.
You have to find your passion.
There's a lot, I've
really evolved, right?
They'll be a lot
on self-awareness.
- [Hollis] Yes.
- They'll be a lot on it's okay
to make $84,000 a year and
sell pots and pans.
There'll be a lot in there so
like I feel, it's definitely,
at some level it's my best
content even though I've not.
Only with DailyVee have
I gotten back to Crush It!
- [Hollis] Yeah.
- I went into marketing.
- [Hollis] Yes.
- This is back to personal brand
and inspiration and
live your best life. Right?
So it's gonna do well
for the same reason
Crush It! did well.
What I'm very excited about guys
and why I do think it could be a
pretty big book is that's a lot
of content and then I want to
build a lot of profiles.
There are a lot of people.
You're gonna basically have
to tell me at some level
what's too exhausting.
Yeah, because
I really want to do it.
My team's gonna
be able to do it.
I'm gonna make them
video every interview.
- I was going to say.
- So we have this insane thing
where we like so what I think
what I'm probably pushing you
with and my intuition from a
selling standpoint is I'd like
to make it as big as you guys
feel comfortable with.
I really think
there's something to that.
- [Hollis] Alright, cool.
- Okay.
- [Hollis] Great.
- [Man 3] Pretty exciting.
- Good to see you again.
- Good to see you.
- Okay, good.
- We'll get it done this year.
- That's what I thought, okay.
Okay, I need to manage for that.
Bye.
("I Want It All" by Jura Kez)
- [Gary] I think with especially
with limited time,
anything, to me, this is
how I love to start stuff.
What's the biggest value?
Completely agnostic, almost as
if I was like a search engine.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] What's the biggest
value that you guys can bring to
your guys' world?
- [Man 4] I'm a big believer
in all our of businesses are
structured around relationships.
We've had a 30 year relationship
with GE and all those guys are
now part of a team.
Those types of, we're family
oriented company and business
and my dad's dad was a plumber
and from Kamenesti (inaudible)
from Belarus to Kamine
because it sounded too Jewish.
- Sure. Of course.
- [Man 4] And so my dad's
been in this business for 20,
30 years and so it's now okay
I'm leveraging a lot
of his network.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And want to build my own
story and be my own man, right?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course
which is a real thing.
As I've gotten to know
well off guys and gals,
there's the one version where,
you know, it's like
you come from zero and it's got
it's advantages and
disadvantages but establishing,
like when I look at my kids I'm
like if one of them is really
ambitious or both of them
that's gonna be a lot of,
that's stuff.
- [Man 4] Yeah.
Making your own course
in that shadow is real.
- [Man 4] There is nothing worse
than being "you're the son of".
- 100%, man.
I even had a little
bit of that with my,
what the fuck are
those guys doing?
- [DRock] I think
they're filming your office.
- [Gary] What are
you guys doing?
- Mind?
Awesome.
- Wish you well.
Thank you brother,
I appreciate it.
Best of luck with everything.
- Yeah.
You too. Thank you, brother,
really appreciate it.
Take care of yourself.
("I Want It All" by Jura Kez)
Hey that was awesome that
that kid got me GaryVee.com.
I'm pumped about that actually.
Yeah, that's very nice.
I don't know if he's expecting
something in return or if he's
being smart and waiting a few
minutes but whenever he comes
back up make sure Tyler
knows, I'll jam with him.
- Anything I need to
know about (censored)?
- [Gary] Yes.
Are they ready?
Are you guys close?
Are we almost ready?
- We will be in
probably 5 minutes.
- [Gary] Okay.
Great, awesome.
What?
'Sup bro, welcome back.
- Inc. magazine wants to ask
you these two of these
questions.
Can I have what
you have right now?
- [DRock] What?
Can you send me whatever
is being recording right now?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Emily] Perfect.
The question is which
unconventional idea in life do
you subscribe to
that most people don't?
(Gary blows raspberry)
(Emily laughs)
Just one?
- You mean all of it?
(Emily laughs)
The whole thing.
That the balance of
extreme ego
and humility is the secret.
- [Emily] Concise.
Okay, this is about life hacks,
what's one of your best life
hacks or unique shortcut that's
immediately usable
for other leaders?
- Ah, well other leaders,
I think that in the age of
technology people are
underestimating the
value of more people.
I hack with people.
Look at all these
fucking characters.
- [Emily] Hack with people to?
- Every leader should hire one
more person to be in their inner
circle and help them scale.
- [Emily] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Who wants to go to
the Pacquiao fight?
- What's going on?
- [Gary] You can make it?
- Yeah. When is it?
- I'll, November 5th.
I'm 97% sure I'm
going so I'll let you know.
How's this going? Good?
Good, I'm looking
forward to the dinner.
How's it going? Good?
Paying attention, Mark?
Did he?
(group laughter)
I'll talk to you later.
Hi. How are you?
Good to see you.
I love the hat.
What's been going on?
I know, I know it's great.
- [Woman 2] I'm talking
with JP Chase today.
- Good.
I'm super excited to see
what we can do together.
- Good stuff, we're
gonna do more stuff.
- Awesome.
- Doing stuff already with
Budweiser and Bud Light.
- Good.
- All that stuff.
- Awesome.
Great to see you.
Hey Brand, how are you?
Are you alright? Seriously?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I did know that,
so that like helps, huh?
I mean you look cool.
- Hey.
- [Gary] Hi.
- We love each other.
Eight TV, five minutes
ANA next week,
if Tyler can fit it in.
- In.
- [Rebecca] And tweet
head of Stratfest.
- In.
- [Rebecca] When do you
want the reminder for it?
- You can send me a text.
I'll do it today.
- [Rebecca] Today. Today's good.
- [Lindsay] (censored).
- (censored),
I haven't looked at it.
- [Lindsay] Well,
what do you want to do?
- What do they want?
- [Lindsay] I have no direction
from you or her in terms of...
- Awesome.
You can do these interviews from
the outside but using the audio
I'd like to, you know?
I'm ready, Ty.
- [Tracy] I'm a
recent college graduate.
I graduated in May.
- Awesome. From where?
- [Tracy] SUNY Purchase.
- Awesome.
- [Tracy] I started out as an
economics major but then I took
a marketing course and
completely fell in love with it.
- Flipped.
- [Tracy] I was first introduced
to you and to VaynerMedia.
- Yep.
- [Tracy] We studied your book
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,"--
- Awesome.
- [Tracy] and since
then I was hooked.
I knew ever since sophomore
year in college that
I wanted to work here.
- That is insane.
- [Tracy] This is
a dream come true.
- That is so awesome.
That makes me so happy.
- [Tracy] Yeah, I wake up every
day so excited to come to work
and I just love it here.
Joe Beth told me on my very
first day that I had to tell you
that I was the on who made
a Snapchat filter
for my interview.
- Yes, I know all
about that actually.
That's awesome.
I'm glad you brought that up.
That was such a good job.
- [Tracy] Thank you.
I actually made one for today.
- No way. Do you have it?
- [Tracy] I was so excited.
Yeah, I do.
- Let's take that
picture right now.
- [Tracy] I think I made
it so I had an excuse to
take a selfie with you.
- Hold on, I'm gonna
give you even more love.
Okay, this is a real effort.
You made a filter for
our gathering,
our quick little meeting.
- [Tracy] I did.
- I love you.
- [Tracy] I was so excited.
- Alright, what's
your Snapchat handle?
- [Tracy] TraceGoldb.
- T-R-A-C.
- [Tracy] T-R-A-C-E-G-O-L-D-B.
So I did opportunity knocked.
- [Gary] (laughs)
That's awesome.
Anything I can answer for you?
- [Tracy] I'm very interested
in how you balance everything.
You have so many commitments
and so many responsibilities--
- Yeah.
- [Tracy] you do such an amazing
job of putting yourself out
there but also
making time for family.
- Yep.
- [Tracy] That's
something you value.
- Yep.
- [Tracy] I'm very curious
about how you balance it all.
- I just try.
I think when you don't cripple
yourself to some standard that
you can't achieve, I just try.
I make every minute count to the
best of my ability and I just
try like, you know?
It's super simple.
- [Tracy] I do, yeah.
- I just try and I think that
in itself like is really how you
pull it off and like if I'm
feeling I'm not spending enough
time with family,
I'll try more there.
If I feel like I need to
spend more time at Vayner,
I'll try more there.
If I feel like I need to put out
more content for my community,
I'll try there.
I adjust to the way I feel and
the signals I'm getting at all
times, always, forever.
- [Tracy] Mhmmm.
Awesome.
I love that answer.
- Cool. It's the truth.
Awesome, well, listen I'm here
for you if you ever need it.
- [Tracy] Yeah,
I really appreciate that.
Love that you make
time for every employee.
- Of course.
Awesome.
Have a great day.
Yeah.
- [Tracy] You too.
- Don't lose that picture.
- [Tracy] Yeah, I won't,
I saved it immediately.
Thank you.
- [Gary] Take care.
And then when you graduated
then you came right to New York?
- [Sophie] Mhmmm.
Yeah, so my first job was
working out of a coworking space
called The Yard.
- The Yard.
- [Sophie] It's like
very similar to WeWork.
- Yeah.
- [Sophie] Little bit
smaller boutique version.
- Yeah.
- [Sophie] And then
I worked at the Barbarian Group.
- Yes.
- [Sophie] Which
I know is like--
- Did you work with Rog?
- [Sophie] Yeah, it's so funny.
I actually worked
directly under Roger.
- No way.
- [Sophie] Yeah.
- That's so cool.
Did you know he was here?
- [Sophie] Yeah.
I did know.
- Did he, when you
thought about it, actually,
how'd you get here?
- [Sophie] So Alex Klein
just messaged me on LinkedIn.
- And where were
you at that point?
Barbarian or somewhere else?
- [Sophie] Barbarian.
- And Barbarian's gone
through a lot of stuff, right?
- [Sophie] Yeah and so it was at
a point right after
the CEO was let go.
- Yeah.
- [Sophie] So I was
like I want to start
looking at other places.
- 'Cause she was
like great and--
- [Sophie] Yeah.
And the structure there for what
I wanted was not working for me
and Roger was also gone at
that time too so there was that.
- When Rog left, did you,
had you heard about Vayner?
Did you know?
- [Sophie] I had not heard
about Vayner at that point.
- Yep.
- [Sophie] I heard
he was coming here.
- Yeah.
- [Sophie] So after that I was
a little more familiar with it.
- Yep.
- [Sophie] So Alex reached
out to me and of course I like
immediately went to Roger.
But was funny was that
I was looking for jobs and Alex
reached out to me and Barbarian
was going through lay offs,
myself included in that.
So the morning I was laid
off was the same day I had my
interview here and I got the
offer the following Tuesday so
it was absolutely perfect.
- (laughs) That
makes me so happy.
- [Sophie] So I was able to
take a two week vacation
and then started here.
- How's it goin'?
- [Sophie] It's been
going really well.
- Good. That makes me happy.
- [Sophie] Yeah.
- Awesome.
This was fun.
- [Sophie] Yes.
Thank you so much.
- Have a great day.
- [Sophie] You too.
- Yeah, take care.
("Save My Life" by Jura Kez)
- We're getting a ton of
response on the video that went
with the Hustler's Digest.
Most I've seen in a long time.
- [Gary] Well which one was it?
- [Tyler] The no
regret or one at-bat.
- Interesting.
- 2:00 to 2:15, cool.
Need anything?
- [Gary] No.
Hi. How are you?
- Good. How are you?
- It's good to see you again.
- Yeah, I know.
- It seems like from my
perspective the net score is at
least on the most macro level
for 750 people, people feel like
the transition's
the right thing.
I think for the people most
affected by it, do you feel
like, I'm glad you're sitting
with me, we have nothing but
good intent for
every individual.
So, all we need to do is know.
What's scary, what's not,
what can I help with,
you know what I mean?
- [Woman 3] Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's
just trying to figure out
how to scale
that really quickly.
- Which part?
Which part?
The IP part or just the
whole transition as a whole?
Awesome.
Have a great day, yeah.
- [Woman 3] Thanks so much.
Yeah, talk to you soon.
It's only 12?
- [DRock] I know.
(laughs)
I literally just saw that.
- How is it only 12?
Oh the media stuff, yeah.
- Yes. (censored) conversation.
- Yeah, keep it
separate for now.
- Cool, and
I'm assuming everything
we're doing there is
driving to Wine Library.
- Where?
- If we're doing content.
- Yeah, we're gonna say these
are the best six wines, yes, the
reason I'm willing to give free
content is pointing some of it
to Wine Library.
- Some, got it.
- Yeah. Doesn't have to be all.
- [Alex] Cool.
- It's not a advertorial.
- Got it.
- And even if it's like
Gary Vaynerchuk was founder of
Wine Library TV and it links to
the and you know what I mean?
- Yep. Find ways to make it fit.
- Yeah.
- [Alex] Thank you.
- Where is this?
Where is this?
Which one?
Hey!
- [Woman 4] How's it going?
- [Gary] 'Sup, brother?
Great to see you, how you been?
It's really good to see you.
Hi.
- Hi.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Woman 4] Good.
- [Gary] All well?
- [Woman 4] How's things?
- [Gary] It's good to see you.
- Yeah, I love the new office.
- [Gary] It's crazy.
- [Denniss] (inaudible).
- [Gary] About us?
Yeah, great.
Anything, got any update?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Can I steal
him for one second?
- Yeah, of course.
Go for it.
Last night was fun,
that was so great.
You love that stuff.
This is a serious room.
Lindsey.
(group laughter)
Alright, cool.
Can you guys hear?
Actually send it over here a
little bit for my little part
and then you'll take it.
So this is super fun.
Great to see everybody.
We don't get to do this
super much and I appreciate
everybody's hustle and
thanks for making time.
So we're gonna announce this
pretty soon and I thought it'd
be important to
announce it to you guys first.
Give you some clarity around
what's happening 'cause I think
there's gonna be a lot of
reaction and questions about it.
All in a positive way,
I actually just anticipate a lot
of people wanting to work in
this division, maybe even more
reaction than the 700
emails I have for VaynerSports.
So in the last six months I've
gone, think about this, for
five, six, seven years I've gone
from zero to 550, and in
six months I've gone from
550 to 1.2 million. Right?
And I think even
you probably know it.
My brand's at a little bit of a
different place than it was even
six months ago and all of it,
all of it has to do with what
I've been building with
Andy and DRock and India.
It's been the content,
the punchline is it's been the
production company
that I built around me.
And it's going to be what
every single person
does in the future.
Every single person is not gonna
have a social media team which
is like their cousin, right?
Everybody's not gonna
pay $7,000 to a PR person.
Take that with a grain of salt.
(group laughter)
I know, I know,
I know, I just want to create
clarity that we're
aligned, don't worry.
I wasn't killing Rebecca.
(group laughter)
The evolution of pay,
if you're Tyra Banks
the evolution of paying
your PR person $7,000 a month
and paying your social media
person that writes tweets for
you $3,000 a month is going to
evolve into VaynerTalent and so
that's what we're gonna build.
We're gonna build a division
that basically takes what we've
done and do it for
individual people.
We are basically, for Todd and
a couple others we're basically
going back to a price point like
early VaynerMedia which is like
you pays $20,000 a
month and we do this.
And that's what we're
gonna do for humans.
What we've done really well is
I create an obnoxious amount of
content because of the strategy
of how we do it, not because,
by the way, it's my five players
versus three players video that
I sent all of you.
When your strategy
is right, you win.
And so we have figured
out that pillar content
creates content
underneath it at scale,
predicated on your talent.
I'm massively quotable and
charismatic and unbelievable.
If you're boring and
don't say anything interesting
it's gonna be harder.
I mean that.
So this meeting is mainly like,
we do enough things that nobody
knows what the fuck is actually
going on 'cause I don't
announce it, this, I don't think
we can build a whole division
without it least
being announced.
(group laughter)
- [Woman 4] Gotcha.
That's fair.
- Yes, though
sometimes I like doing it.
'Cause they're unofficial.
What (censored) office?
(group laughter)
Alright, cool. Good?
(group affirms)
Awsome.
Cool.
Awesome.
(group applause)
I'm just saying hello,
one more second.
Who you meeting with today?
- You.
- You are? What time?
- 2:00?
- What?
Come, that's what
I was worried about.
Hey, Tyler.
I want you to figure
out what's going on here.
We'll figure it out.
Thinks he's seeing me.
Mhmmm.
- [Zak] Okay.
- Oh, Shoots, what do you want?
- [Dan] DRock.
- Dan.
- I'll still come back every
day just to be on
the show, you know?
- It'll be interesting, you
will be in it at times, right?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna be in LA
Monday through Thursday.
- I don't know if we ever had
a situation quite like that at
Vayner, right?
I don't think so.
- [Dan] No worries,
be in the building.
- Yeah, like you'll be
here probably a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You know?
Probably seven, nine
times a year kind of thing.
- I thought you were going
to say nine times a week.
(group laughter)
Well...
- This one's for a client.
- [Tyler] Did you see what
the Dodgers did last night?
- I did.
- [Tyler] With their closer.
They brought him in.
- [Tyler] In the seventh.
- Yep.
- [Tyler] And that whole
movement that's going on.
- That what?
- [Tyler] Just that whole
movement of saving your closer
to the ninth is stupid.
- Because of what
happened with the Orioles.
- [Tyler] Stats show that first
off, two through four hitters
come up in the eighth more times
than not and that's who you
should put your
best pitcher against.
The data's just coming out,
like Mariano who
lost a ton of leverage in
that they always put him in
the ninth inning and then had a
reliever pitch in the eighth
against their best hitters and
give up runs there and then
Mariano wouldn't even get to...
- That's why the Yanks
were so dominant when it
was Mariano and Wetteland.
- [Tyler] And then when
it was just Mariano--
- Yep.
- [Brandon] Call you back in 10.
- Of course you have prices
on every wine in the flyer.
- [Brandon] Right but what we're
saying is $14.99 if you come in
the store and $12.99 if
you do it online, right?
- You do that everyday.
It's called a discount code.
- [Brandon] Yep, okay.
- Am I right?
- [Brandon] We've never said it
in this way,
you know what I mean?
That's all.
Maybe I'll reword it a
little bit to make it easier.
- [Gary] Sure.
Make yourself feel better.
- [Brandon] Fine.
- Hey.
- [Brandon] Yeah?
- Did we sell anything today?
- [Brandon] Sold a little,
nothing great yet but I will
have more stuff for
you soon, promise.
- [Gary] And what
about the try this?
- [Brandon] Three cases.
- Of what?
- [Brandon] Of the
Healdsburg Ranches Merlot.
- Yep. Alright, see you.
- [Brandon] Yeah, alright, bye.
- Feel good.
I like when I get stuff done.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Caught up and like,
I like when I put out fires.
Makes me breathe easier.
Sid.
Hey.
- Hello.
- [Gary] Where's the, what?
Hey, how are you?
That's cool.
That's super cool.
I didn't see them fix it up.
Hey, 'sup Anna?
So like, you're married.
Yeah, Maggie emailed me
I'm like that's so weird
with the last name.
- Switched her
name, I was confused.
- [Gary] I was, I had heard
that you were gonna
switch your name.
- Oh, I really wanted.
- [Gary] Hey everyone.
How you guys doin'?
- Good.
- [Gary] All well?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Cool.
Have a great day.
(group laughter)
- Oh, what's up?
- 'Sup, bro?
- [Man 5] How you doin'?
- [Gary] Talking to Maggie?
- [Man 5] Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] What's going on?
- [Man 8] Just helping me out.
- 'Sup bro, how you doing?
- Good.
- [Gary] Good to see you guys.
What's going on?
- [Man 6] What's going on?
- [Gary] Good.
You guys cold?
- [Man 5] A little bit.
- A little bit.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Yeah, this is rad.
- [Man 5] Let's get
this going actually.
- [Gary] That was Tyler's fault.
He fucked up.
(group laughter)
Seriously. He made
a huge mistake.
He thought it was here.
- Yeah, I saw on the invite it
was somewhere on Hudson Street.
- [Gary] He got confused
because it said Hudson Street.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] And he just,
his eye overlooked it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You
should really razz him.
You should send him an email
and be like you destroyed his
day.
He destroyed your day.
All good?
- [Man 5] DRock, let's get
a closeup on the fountain.
- [Gary] Dude, how do you
feel like owing like
$78,000 to the league?
- You know, I asked my parents
about it and they were like
it's A, way too late to
ask for this kind of loan,
B, you're our
least favorite child and
C, that's a lot
to pony up right now.
So my only chance, I got to ask
the prize next year be $78,000.
- [Gary] $78,000.
Sounds right.
- [Man 6] That I can win.
- [Gary] Understood.
You guys alright?
How you doin', DRock?
Having a good day?
- [DRock] Yes, I am.
- [Gary] Good.
What are you talking about?
I'm always super,
I actually think I'm super easy.
It's rare for me to
do what I just did.
I'll be right back.
Is he here?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
Ladies.
- [Both] Hello.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Tyler] Where you go going?
- [DRock] Yeah, where you going?
- [Gary] I thought he was going
to do an UberPool so he could
get a quick date.
(group laughter)
- [Tyler] GeeV, over here, bud.
- [Gary] Okay.
That was a good one.
Andy!
- You need anything?
- [Gary] I'll take a coffee.
We didn't get, we
didn't really get to it.
I gave him a huge compliment
on his sneaker poster.
- I went for the
wrong bottle of wine.
- Yeah. Loved it?
- I was like shit.
(group laughter)
This is amazing.
- I knew that was
going to blow people away.
("Working Together" by Jura Kez)
- [Gary] I feel like it's the
kind of thing you should
sink your teeth into.
You don't need to become the
(censored) expert but you need
to help me build it.
Does that make sense?
- [Man 8] Sure.
- This is something that can
really be an impact
on you personally.
Dig into this.
- [Man 8] Yep.
- Really, you know what I mean?
- [Man 8] Sure.
- Dig into this.
- [Man 8] Cool.
- [Gary] Do you see it,
do you see it too?
- I do. It's internet
1.0 all over again
but in a different way because
now it's much more enabled
'cause there's so much more
technology at stake.
- [Gary] You gotta understand,
I'm really excited about it
because I think this could
be really carved out for you.
Like, I don't know if it
interests you and that's why I'm
not pushing too hard but if
you're asking me agnostically
something that's ownable that
can be quite substantial--
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- that can be beneficial to
you and you're built for,--
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- I think this is it.
- [Man 8] Cool.
- [Gary] In my way,
just the way I view you,
you're here for this moment.
I know that you're the right
player and it's always like
players in a
position to succeed,
we've done many things
already together--
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- I think this has a shot.
You're sitting with
Sally and Rick--
- [Man 8] Yeah.
- and learning and knowing.
This is, again, I'm agnostic,
you don't have to but you need
to seriously think about
this being something that
could be really big.
- [Man 8] Good.
Thanks, man.
- [Gary] Yeah, I think it's a
good, I'm really excited about
it but don't use my
excitement to push you to do it.
You know what I mean?
I'm empathetic to that.
- [Man 8] Yeah, I hear you.
- You know?
Give it some thought.
But you don't have to love it.
I think it's there, man.
I want you to really help me,
I want you to put some real
fucking work on this.
I want five or six names from
you with links of like we need
to hire this person.
- [Man 8] Cool.
- Figure it out. Yeah.
I have unbelievable seats for
you two unbelievable seats in
LA for Tuesday and Wednesday and
I think you and
Sitomer should go.
Well, let's talk about it.
Let's talk about it.
Well, let's talk about, aren't
you going already you said?
And so what is that?
That's when and when?
Tuesday, Wednesday,
Monday, Wednesday.
Okay, so you're definitely going
to LA Tuesday because you can
fly into San Francisco Wednesday
morning on the 6 AM flight.
- [Brandon] But I have
to change the flight.
- Brandon, you don't understand.
Let me remind you.
Do you remember when you
lived upstairs from me?
- [Brandon] Yes.
- And do you remember when
I would always say to you like
you should come and hang because
we're gonna regret this because
one day we're gonna married
and we can't just hang out like.
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- Good.
That's what's
happening again right now.
- [Brandon] It's
just a lot of money.
It's a lot of money to
change, I'm not arguing.
(inaudible)
- No, you're doing
this and that's that.
You're going
Tuesday and Wednesday.
Start looking at flights.
I'm gonna have Tyler, Garrett,
Garrett, Garrett email Brandon
right now I'm forcing him to
go to the Tuesday and Wednesday
games of the Cubs in LA.
I want you to help with him with
flights 'cause I trust you more
than I trust him so email him
right now your cell number.
Call Garrett he's
gonna help you.
Alright?
- [Brandon] Yes.
- [Gary] Okay, good.
I love you more, bye.
What?
- The $50K that you
donated when you were on stage.
- [Gary] What?
- The $50K that you donated
when you were on stage,--
- Yes, I'm gonna do that
by the end of the year.
Let him know.
Let him know there's some tax
stuff but it will
100% happen by the year.
- [Tyler] I think he's
gotten a shitload of influence.
- I know, I know.
- Okay, cool.
I'll let him know that.
Will it be
personal or will it be?
- It'll be personal.
- Okay, cool.
Hi.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Good.
Jocelyn.
Jocelyn, you hurt your finger?
- [Jocelyn] Yeah.
- What happened?
- [Jocelyn] I originally hurt it
playing basketball and then--
- [Gary] First of all,
that's awesome.
I love you for that.
(Jocelyn laughs)
- And then I re-hurt it just
like pure stupidity honestly.
I tripped and slammed
my finger in a mailbox.
- [Gary] (laughs) I love it.
That was perfect.
How are you?
- [Jocelyn] Good.
- Good. Anything
I can answer for you?
- I was just curious
what's going on in your life?
- Not much.
(Gary and Jocelyn laughing)
- Not really.
- Vayner.
Vayner.
My day's just filled
with headaches and I'm just
trying to like I really
meant what I just said to you.
I work for you.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- I don't know what
else to tell you.
When you take on the
responsibility to be the last
line of defense,
it's all your fault.
All of it.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- And so, I feel a huge
gratitude in everybody's trust
and a huge sense responsibly
to deliver for everybody like
I think we're really building
something for real like
not just lip service.
It's just very black-and-white
to me, I know we are and I want
to see through and I want to
really deliver so I feel like
public, great pressure.
- [Jocelyn] That's a lot.
- You know?
It's just five offices,
800 people almost now.
Not to mention all, you know
just like all the other stuff
that goes along with like my
life, like the content and the
books and the speaking and being
pulled in a million directions,
it is a lot but
like I made my bed.
I can't complain about
sleeping in it, you know?
- [Jocelyn] Yeah.
- And then let's really get to
the punchline, in the world of
8 billion people
I'm going to be okay.
Do you know I mean?
I can't even to begin to,
I think coming from immigrant
background and things of that
nature like my perspective
is on fucking point.
I'm very aware of how awesome
it is so, yeah,
it's a lot of pressure.
Great, so then don't do it.
Sell the company, downsize it.
I've made it's like I like want
to instill that on
the rest of the org.
You're a big girl.
Whatever problems the biggest
reason I'm giving you this
little rant is I want you to
know that if you ever have
anything, I'm here.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- Like email me.
- [Jocelyn] Okay.
- You know?
Have you met Claude yet?
- [Jocelyn] I haven't.
- You have to
email her, right now.
- [Jocelyn] Okay.
- I'm forcing you.
- You have to go to
your desk and email her.
And be like I want her
to know who you are.
This horse shit, it's way
more real than you think.
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- Take advantage of it.
You stumbled into it,
fucking take advantage of it.
- [Jocelyn] Okay.
- Do you understand?
- [Jocelyn] Yeah. I'll do that.
Email Claude, email Steve.
- You know?
- [Jocelyn] Mhmmm.
- It's good and you should
get the most benefit from it.
- [Jocelyn] I will.
- Cool.
- [Jocelyn] Yeah.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Have a great day.
- [Jocelyn] Thanks.
- Yeah. I hope
your finger gets better.
- [Jocelyn] Thanks.
- Zak!
- [DRock] Zak.
- [Gary] Come here, Zak.
(DRock laughing)
- Are you taking a picture?
- [Gary] Zak, please
come here because
I need to understand.
Is that your
Pokémon ball balloon?
- Yeah.
- Who got it for you?
Hurry, one second.
- The team.
- Kara.
- How are you, Kara?
- Good.
- What's been going on?
- Not much.
- How long have
you been here now?
- Since February.
So like, eight months
I think it is.
- How's it going?
- It's good, I like it a lot.
- Good, tell me about yourself.
- I'm from Long Island.
I went to Stevens in Hoboken.
Did lacrosse there.
- Did you?
- Yeah.
- That's awesome.
- Right out of school I started
working for an architect.
I went to school for
marketing information systems.
- It's very basic.
I'm not a hero or
the greatest guy ever.
I'm just building
something forever.
- You're just
saying it differently.
- 100%.
- I buy that.
It's just--
What's broke?
And it's a simple
fix half the time.
It's just think
about it differently.
I don't know,
I talk to people who--
And I'll be honest with you,
when a recruiter hit
me up for the job.
I'd never heard of
VaynerMedia before.
- I get it.
- I don't mean
that in a douchey way--
- No, no, no.
You have to understand.
I'm the most egotistical
and the most humble.
- Yeah.
- Like, I don't think
any real creative
thinks this is a real--
doesn't know this.
- No.
- 'Cause we don't
play that game.
- [Adam] No, you don't.
- We're inventing the
next version of the game.
- [Adam] Yeah. Yeah.
- Every 13-year-old you,--
- [Adam] Yeah.
- is gonna dream to work here.
- [Adam] 100%, because,
when I grew up it was the
Chiat Days or the whatever
that were doing
the stuff, and now--
- Did you know very early on
this was what you wanted to do?
- [Adam] Advertising?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean,
I was in grade ten.
Sydney.
I'm from Sydney, Australia.
I was grade ten and I went
and did work for Disney.
I wanted to be an animator.
And I kind of realized within--
It's fantastic, in grade ten
they send you to do two weeks
work experience.
- And in five
seconds you're like--
- You realize that your dream
is not what you wanted to do.
And no one's gonna go like,
my dream would've been to play
for Phoenix Suns.
But, I was never gonna do that.
So I couldn't go and do that.
So I went and did the--
- I had a similar dream.
My dream was to actually
play for New York Jets.
It's just, when I realized
I couldn't do that I said
you know what?
Fuck it, I'll just buy it.
(laughs)
- And I love that. I love that.
I love that.
And I mean I hope you get there,
it'd be freaking amazing.
- You might design the new logo.
- That would be great.
I'm a Giants fan, but
I don't hold that against you
because I honestly,
I arrived here and I was
like, I gotta pick a team.
And I was kind of Cardinals.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- 'cause I just grew up
loving Charles Barkley
and I hated Jordan.
I hated Jordan.
- Yeah, I hate Jordan
with all my life.
- And I was like, Barkley's
the guy who gives the finger
to the organization
and I love that.
So I love Dan Marley.
- Thunder Dan.
The Knick's new
coach is Hornacek.
- Oh, and he was
with Suns coach.
- Yeah.
- So, I'm a huge, I go
every year to see the Suns--
- Is Nate here?
Oh no, Nate.
Yo, get Nate.
So Nate, who used to be my
assistant for years, and is--
You have to meet him,
he's a real Suns fan.
- Oh, man, I'm legit,
we should--
- You guys are gonna have
to go to a game together.
- Yeah, no, amazing.
Howdy, man.
- Nate.
- Do you know Adam Lock?
- No.
- I don't think so.
- [Gary] Great news.
He's a real Suns fan.
- [Nate] Yeah.
- I flew twice from Sydney
just to Phoenix to watch games
and flew home again.
- Why'd you become a Suns fan?
- [Gary] Charles Barkley,
he hated Jordan.
- I loved Charles Barkley,
I hated Jordan and I was like.
- '96 when I got into
basketball.
- Nate, when--
Well, 'cause you're both
bandwagon fans,
that's when they were good.
Okay, well you're also young.
When are Knicks
playing the Suns?
- [Nate] 21st.
- Of?
- [Nate] Here?
- Yeah.
- [Nate] January 21st.
- Do we have tickets
for that game?
- [Nate] Yeah.
- Okay, cool, awesome.
- [Nate] Nice to meet you.
- We'll see if Adam
makes it to January.
- [Adam] We gotta set up a
slack channel for us.
Just the Suns channel,
you and me.
- [Nate] For sure,
there's none of us here.
- [Gary] Are there no Suns fans?
- I guess Chanel.
Chanel's from Arizona,
but very few.
- Chanel Perez?
Is she a Suns fan though?
- There's like two dance
teams for the Suns,
she was on one
of the dance teams.
- Oh, that's cool.
- [Adam] That's fair enough.
- She was an employee.
- [Nate] Does that mean
she's a fan though?
- We'll have to
figure it out later.
(light music)
- [Gary] What else has
been going on with you?
- Just been working a lot, yeah.
- [Gary] Oh, do you
work with him?
- Yeah.
[Gary] Awesome.
- It's funny, I met him
- [Gary] Where's he from?
about seven years ago.
Tel Aviv, Israel.
And he travels all
around the world.
He's like you on planes, but
he's never really in one place.
- [Gary] Yeah.
So, he has an agent that he
works with in New York City,
he said, hey, you know,
we're gonna just do a show,
because eventually they
wanna do some Broadway thing,
so they threw him in
Caroline's in a full house
and it's kinda cool.
- [Lior] Yes!
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Lior] It was fun.
- I figured we'd
come in here, and,
- How are you? I'm Gary.
- Thank you for having
us here, it's great.
- Yeah, no worries.
- I actually, on the way
here, I was on the elevator,
I want to ask you a question,
I'm gonna write something here.
- [Gary] You got it.
- Because we're shooting this,
(laughing)
- [Gary] By the way,
thank god I can't do this
because I'd be the worst.
- Go straight to Gary,
Gary look at the camera,
- Yes.
- And tell us a
two digit number.
Whatever you want,
just say something.
- One Five.
- [Lior] So it's 15?
- Yes.
- I wrote here,
"Gary will say 15."
(people laughing)
- I don't know what
else to tell you.
- Do you see?
- I see it.
- Yes, so why did you say
15? This is the question.
- Because you put it in my head.
- It's close to this,
it's close to this, yes.
Hi, you guys, nice to meet you.
Very awkward
moment here, but it's fun.
- [Gary] It's fucking the best.
I believe in this shit
completely, by the way.
- It's not about
believing or not.
First of all, it's about
experiencing.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I always say to people,
it's not supernatural powers,
it's based on psychology.
I'll ask you a quick question,
and try to go really fast.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Tell me the name
of your first kiss.
- Kim.
- [Lior] Kim, okay, so
by saying this to you,
this causes the entire room
to start thinking of the name,
- Yep.
- [Lior] And you
think of the name,
and you think of the name,
and you think of the name.
- Yep.
- [Lior] Uh, Lindsay.
- [Lindsay] Mhmmm?
- [Lior] I'm just
looking at you right now.
- [Lindsay] Yeah?
- Let me tell you the process,
just for clarification, you
did not tell me the name.
- [Lindsay] Sure.
- Look at me,
look at me, look at me.
Do you know the
name of her first kiss?
- [Gary] No.
- Okay, so just,
- [Linday] (laughing) That
would be weird if you did.
- Just think of a letter
in the middle of the name,
but don't say it.
- [Lindsay] Okay.
- Okay, you just had "D."
(Lindsay laughing)
Had a "D",
can you videotape
her for a second?
- Did you catch that?
(people laughing)
- [Lior] Did you felt something?
You felt something,
and I'm gonna write
something for you here.
- [Gary] It's so impressive,
right?
- [Lior] Now, I swear we
don't know each other.
- Nothing, I'm aware.
We're not on stage here.
- [Lior] It seems to be very
(mumbles) about this moment,
that we don't know each other.
- [Gary] By the way,
this is the best moment that
ever happened in my life.
- [Lior] Oh, I love it!
- No, no, I'm being
dead serious.
This is the best
moment of my life.
You have to understand,
I love this so much.
there is so logical science
explanation for that.
- Exactly.
- You have to understand,
I don't have this,
unfortunately,
(laughing)
but I have something,--
- [Lior] I know.
- in the way that
I live my life,--
- [Lior] Mhmmm.
- that is a cousin to this,
that makes me
understand it's possibility.
- [Lior] Exactly.
- Like, everything I say is
gonna happen to me, happens.
- [Lior] I will say you
that people think
the universe listens, basically.
- I genuinely believe that, man.
- [Lior] Hold this,
don't show her that.
- Okay.
- [Lior] Don't show her.
I wrote something over there.
What was your age when
you had your first kiss?
- [Lindsay] Oh, god, uh, 13?
- [Lior] 13? So that's like a,--
- I'm impressed, very nice girl.
- [Lindsay] Thank you.
- [Lior] So, I need you to
look at the camera dramatically
- Oh, man.
- [Lior] Yes, and
tell us the name.
- Well, aren't you
gonna tell me the name?
- [Gary] No, you
tell the camera.
- [Lior] I already wrote
something, just say the name.
- His name is Eddie.
- [Lior] Eddie?
Can you show her what I?
(yelling)
- He's so good!
It's so good!
- It wasn't a real kiss.
(laughing)
- [Lior] Wait, go back to me,
go back to me.
So, Eddie, if you're
watching this right now.
- [Lindsay] Oh my god.
- You thought of "B,"
by the way,
the letter "B"
when she was thinking of,
Yeah? You had "B" in your mind.
(laughing)
- You'll like this.
When I was saying my number,
five came to me,
'cause it always does,
it's my favorite number,
but I was about
to say something,
and instead I said to 15.
- You changed your mind,
that was me influencing you.
- I know that.
I genuinely believe you.
I actually could feel it happen.
- Mhmmm, mhmmm.
(Lindsay laughing)
- I know you guys
know me a little bit.
I get it, I literally get it.
I was trying to
say something else,
it's amazing, I'm actually
just going backwards right now,
I was trying to
say something else
and I was forced to say 15.
I'm telling you guys,
that's the truth.
- So I have to tell
you something,
something that you'll love.
- Can I harness this?
(Lindsay laughing)
I feel like, I feel like.
- When first we came here,
I saw all the people working,
I said, listen, we need to
arrange a show
here for everyone.
- Done!
- Blow their minds with,--
- Done.
When are you back in New York?
- I don't know yet,
but we'll figure it out.
- Okay, Tyler, make it happen.
We'll do a company-wide event.
- Yes, cool.
- [Gary] How much do you
care about your legacy?
- Oh, that's something new
that I started to think of.
That's very,
very important for me.
- [Gary] Yeah, it should be.
- Yeah, I just, you know,
did I tell you about my dream?
I was talking to,
I have a lot of dreams
and thoughts about this,
and I thought, okay,
I know my dad, my grandfather,
I remember
his father, but that's it.
So you don't remember
who was his dad, right?
And that's like
100 years, that's it.
It's nothing.
- That's what this is,
my friend.
Right now, my great,
great, great, great,
great granddaughter is
watching this right now.
[Lior] Will.
- [Lior] Or is, if we're
talking about (mumbles)
- So, do you know
what I mean, though?
- [Lior] Of course, yeah.
- It's fucking cool.
- But you're also (mumbles)
He's got two children, and all,
Tel Aviv-based.
- [Lior] Yeah.
- [Man 9] He's on a plane
probably 180 days a year.
- [Lior] 176, he's more.
- [Man 9] Yeah.
- 177 for me.
- [Lior] Ah!
- I wrote it down right here.
(group laughing)
- Oh, my God!
(yells)
(laughing)
- [Lior] God, oh my god.
- [Man 9] So, those are
things where I just thought.
- By the way,
the most interesting
part of this was,
I was literally able to feel
me being forced to say it.
- [Lior] Yep, yeah, yeah.
- Do a lot of people get that?
- [Lior] Not a lot.
- That's why I feel
like I've got something.
- [Lior] Because you
are very sensitive.
- I mean it.
- [Lior] Very sensitive.
- I'm the most sensitive.
- [Lindsay] We know!
(group laughing)
- No, really, it's real!
And, know what? Xander,--
- I'm stealing your
phone here, Gary.
- Okay, no problem.
Xander's showing it.
- You have your password?
- [Lindsay] Really?
- Yes.
- I know your password,
that's fine.
- [Lindsay] That's amazing.
- Yes.
(group laughing)
- [Lindsay] Do you
think he's going to be
more sensitive than you?
- [Gary] I don't know,
and actually,
that would be one place
where I wouldn't be competitive.
That would make me happy,
'cause I think it's special.
- [Lindsay] Yeah.
- Where is the code?
Yep, okay.
So, you need to
change your password.
- [Gary] No problem.
- It's a fun game.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Fun game.
You press a two digit number.
- [Gary] Two git?
- Two digit, whatever you want.
- Okay.
- Nope, just two.
And you press "plus",
- Okay.
- [Lior] And what you do,
don't think about it.
- Okay.
- [Lior] Just use your
intuition, you'll be fine.
- Yep, yep.
- If this works,
I will be in shock.
You keep going, is it 91?
- Yes.
- You already did "plus", right?
- I hit "plus", yes.
- Okay, so one more
number, two digits again,
- Two digits again?
- Yes, and "plus" again,
and you keep doing it,
different numbers.
- Keep going?
- Yes, two digits,
boom, "plus", two digits
plus, and just,
can you go faster?
- Yes.
- Just "plus", da, da, "plus",
da, da, "plus", very good.
And now go to three digits.
Da da, "plus", da, da, da,
"plus", da, da, da, "plus".
Stop!
Divide.
- Divide?
- A two digit number.
Equal?
Score?
- 52109?
- (slam) Crazy.
That's your number.
Yeah, that's your number.
- That's my number?
- Yep, that's 52901, 09? 52109?
(laughter)
- So great!
- No, but you know what
is special about 52101?
I say it's your number, yes?
It's your number, actually,
Gary, it's G-A and R and Y.
(laughing)
- Your face was,
(laughing, group cheering)
I fucking love it.
- Do you have glasses?
It's the grand finale.
Sunglasses?
- [Gary] No.
- Up there.
- [Lindsay] Oh, on your chest.
- Yeah, but again,
I'm not using mine.
And I need you to come over here
and do a over-the-shoulder shot.
And you, come here,
and I want you to,
we'll put it over here.
Come, come, come, and,
your first kiss
got a weird name.
- [Tyler] Yeah,
super weird name.
- [Lior] Where is she from?
- She,
- [Lior] She's not from America?
- The last name would
not be American, no.
- [Lior] Like a,
- It was a last name.
- [Lior] Oh, a last name.
- Yeah.
- [Lior] Oh, really, wow.
- [Lior] Like "Ebil?" "Ibil?"
- Is that where it's from,
you're asking?
- [Lior] No, the name's close?
Am I close?
- Yeah, a little bit.
- [Lior] What's the name?
- Taybi.
- [Lior] Taybi? Okay, I
was close, I was close.
- [Tyler] You had the "B."
- Exactly.
Gary, do it, just wave
your hand above the glasses
and tell me what you feel.
- Nothing.
- [Lior] That's the point.
- Okay.
- [Lior] You see the
middle of the glasses?
- I do.
- Watch with me, you ready?
You watching?
So, look in this area.
Come from this side.
Yeah, just look here.
Watch.
(slam)
- [Gary] Yeah, I just, you know.
(everyone laughs)
It's the best, man.
The short term
and the long term,
- [Lior] Sure.
- [Gary] And then I can
really do some stuff.
- Okay.
- We'll figure it out.
- And arrange something because
I want to freak all of you.
- I will, you know what?
That's what we'll do.
Why don't we arrange
something right away
for a company event,
and then we'll spend the
hour and a half after,
we'll talk.
I mean, here's the punchline:
Why Lindsay's here is
we're building something
that is the future of all this,
which is what DRock's doing.
It's a human production company,
- Right.
- And, I don't need to sell it,
I need to show it to you guys.
- Yeah, it's special.
- And then we'll figure
out what that means.
- I just have fun with it.
- Yeah, okay.
- I have a blast.
Thanks for taking the time.
- Alright, of course.
Great to see you.
Have a great day.
- If you want him to screw
with some people for fun,
(laughing)
- It's amazing, just amazing.
- It will kill all
your productivity.
- Dude, it's the most amazing,
I totally get it, though.
- [Man 9] Alright, thank you.
- Take care.
- Alright, see you later.
(light music)
- Yeah, no worries.
- Cool alright so I'll jump
right into it and make it quick.
So I'm going through a
part of my life right now
where I'm having
some internal dissonance
and in short it's really
balancing being
a 21-year-old man
and a 21-year-old kid.
And strictly with values.
Meaning, should I take risks,
should I do something that's
responsible towards
people that, you know,
have given me things,
like my family.
Should I reciprocate?
So my name's Isaac Kassin.
I'm 21 years old.
I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
I'm here to discuss
some personal things
with Gary regarding my future.
I started a financial
technology company,
raised a bunch of money,
but I have a little
dissonance because I'm also
attending NYU Stern and
I have to figure out
how to balance the both.
- Well then that's the game.
- [Isaac] That's just the game.
- That's the game.
That you can't, yeah,
I'm glad we're talking
because that is the game.
That's what you're
signing up for.
Nobody can protect
you from that.
That's not what you want
to be protected about.
Got it?
- [Isaac] I see
what you're saying.
- You understand?
- [Isaac] Mhmmm.
- Like, you can't have it
just the way you want it.
- [Isaac] It's a trade
off, isn't it?
- This morning I had a meeting
and I was telling my
executive, and I'm like look,
if we're playing
a different game,
it's great when you're
playing a different game
and it's good.
But when you're playing
a different game
you gotta also eat the shit
that comes along with it.
Super fun to fucking
be an entrepreneur
at 21 and play the game.
If you fucking lose, you lose.
It really doesn't suck.
What you need to do,
and I think you
wouldn't be sitting here
if you don't know my spiel.
What you need to do is
figure out if you have
the stomach for it or not and
if you don't that's cool too.
But you need to
figure out that out.
How bout you default
in two minutes.
How bout you
default until you don't.
- What do you mean?
Say that again.
- How bout you take your
brain into a place where
you say you won't succeed.
And give up the equity.
- [Isaac] Interesting.
So just accept the downside
'cause then the upside
is that it's like oh I won.
- And more importantly once
you fully accept the downside
then you'll know if you
really want to do it.
- [Isaac] I dig that.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Isaac] Yeah.
- That's how I live my life.
I live my life everyday
as if my family died.
And then that's why I'm so
fucking happy every day.
- [Isaac] Listen, it's a very,
very deep philosophical issue
as well 'cause it
involves my family.
There's a lot of moving
elements so I think that
it's an ongoing thought
process and discussion.
But Gary was nice enough
to tell me that I could
reach back out and
follow up with him
so hopefully definitely I'll
be lead in the right direction
in the coming months.
- [Gary] And here's
what I will say,
the only decision
that needs to be made
is the one that you will regret
the least when you're 90.
- [Isaac] Wow.
- You know?
- [Isaac] I like that.
- That's the only one.
Which one? One sec...
I'm glad you stopped by man.
I hope I brought you some value.
You know,
it's a challenging one.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Here's what
you have to do.
- [Isaac] Wish you
had more time together.
- Don't be a hypocrite.
- [Isaac] Yeah.
- But also, but listen,
don't be stubborn.
Losing in the short term
because you do think Stern's
the right way is fine.
- [Isaac] It's fine.
- It's super fine. But--
- [Isaac] But if I
decide to go to school--
- Super fine.
You got a lot of time.
But if this is what
you feel you need to do
then you need to do it
and you can't expect
them to be making
you all the money.
What are you gonna take
risk with a parachute?
Take risks. It's not
fair on your brothers.
- [Isaac] Okay.
- Alright, good luck man.
We'll talk soon again.
- I appreciate it (mumbles).
- Take care. No worries.
Yeah, I would love to know.
I would love to know. Take care.
That was interesting.
- I'm doing pretty good.
I'm doing great. I was
wondering, I'm like,
you know, it's cool
to finally meet you.
(laughing)
I don't know what to say.
- Thanks.
- [Man 9] I will
say one thing.
- Please.
- [Man 9] I've done a little
research 'cause I'll be honest
with you I didn't know
exactly who you were.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- 'Cause I've been working
in the building for a while.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- And you know, coming
into this, I'm like,
I wonder who this guy is.
You know we actually had
to do a bit of research.
- [Gary] When the company
was first moving in?
- When the company was
first moving in and I'm like
okay so let me do a
little research to see
who, you know, who's coming in.
And I watched a
few of your videos.
I saw a couple of your
books and I'm just like,
this guy really knows
what he's talking about.
(Gary laughs)
No, he's really
making things happen.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So, yeah, it's a pleasure
to finally meet you.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
How'd the Vayner
people bringing vibe?
- Amazing. No, let me
just be honest with you
and I tell people
this all the time,
VaynerMedia is
the coolest company
that we have in the building.
- [Gary] I love it.
- Everyone is really
chill and laid back.
And really easy
to get along with.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I will say that, for sure.
- [Gary] That matter to me.
How they interact matters.
- Yeah. They're awesome.
- [Gary] Good.
You guys, you can tell who
works at Vayner, right?
- Well, for the most part.
- [Gary] You never know.
- With the make up and things.
- [Gary] Yeah, Yeah. (laughing)
- It's really chill.
- [Gary] Good man. So what's
going on in your world?
- Nothing much, you know.
I'm actually engaged.
So I'm actually planning out
my wedding 'cause, you know,
- [Gary] Good for you.
- That's in a couple of months,
but that's like taking up
most of my time right now.
- [Gary] Good for you.
That's awesome.
And how long you been?
What were you
doing before this building?
- Before this building, I was
actually still pretty much
working for Related,
the company.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But I was working at a mall.
So I pretty much
was like responsible
for everything going on--
- [Gary] Where?
- In Flushing, Queens.
- Oh is that right?
Yep, I know it.
That's very cool.
- [Man 10] It was
pretty interesting.
- He's built an
amazing company. Related.
- [Man 10] Yeah, definitely.
- Incredible. Incredible.
Anything I can help you with?
- [Man 10] Well you know what?
- What?
- [Man 10] Just being
able to sit down with you
and talk to you today is great.
- I appreciate that.
- [Man 10] I really
feel like there's a lot
that I can learn from you.
I'm actually not too
far behind you in age.
- Okay.
- [Man 10] I'm 38.
I'll be 39 in March.
- You look good.
- [Man 10] So, well thank
you I appreciate it.
I'd like to be able to
move upward in life and--
- [Gary] Good for you.
- But sometimes you
get a little stuck.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And watching the videos
and seeing a lot of things
that you've had to say
it's been really helpful.
- [Gary] What's been
the, what's the one that
sticks with you the most?
- Get up off your ass. You know?
- There's just nothing else.
It's so black and white.
Like, you know, it's so crazy.
I literally think that I only
believe in a couple of things.
Like, it's interesting.
Isn't it?
- [Man 10] Yeah.
- I think what's weird for
me, is for some reason,
when I say it people...
Maybe cause
I believe it so much.
I don't know.
- [Man 10] I dare say,
not only is it because
you believe it so much
but it's also because
you've actually, you've
actually gotten off your ass.
- (Laughing) Right. Right.
I've done it. Right.
Sure.
- [Man 10] There is so many...
- That's a good point.
- [Man 10] That you've taken
your family wine business
- Yep, yep.
- [Man 10] and you've made it
this multimillion
dollar business.
You've done so
many different things
and that's so commendable.
And I'm lookin to
do pretty much something
- Well listen, let's you know,
take value out of this meeting.
You got my inbox.
If anything pops in your
head between now and forever
you ping me and I'll be
more than happy to listen.
- [Man 10] I definitely
will. I definitely will.
I appreciate it.
- No worries. Alright.
- [Man 10] Alright,
I appreciate you.
- Yeah, have a great weekend.
- I definitely will.
You do the same.
- Yeah, I'm around.
- Alright, cool.
- Let me know
if you need anything.
- I will.
- Keep an eye..the thing is
if you watch a DailyVee
and you see something and
you're like oh, you know?
- [Man 10] Yeah, I definitely
will. I definitely will.
- Good. Take care.
(mumbling)
- [Jake] Yo.
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Jake] What's good, bro?
- [Gary] Good to see you, bro.
- [Jake] How are you?
- [Gary] You were in Jersey?
- [Jake] Yeah.
- [Gary] Dude,
that's so amazing.
What's up man, good to
see you. How ya been?
All well?
- [Jake] This is the office?
- This is it!
- There's not even a computer.
- What?
- You leave here?
- [Woman 5] Yeah.
- Okay.
We're doin it.
- [Connor] Love
your digs, man.
- I love it. We're doing
like two for one kinda thing?
Like whole crew?
- [Tyler] We're doing
like guest and two hosts.
- They're the hosts.
I love it. Got it.
- So this is Gary.
Gary this is--
- I remember.
- Hi.
- Hi. Sorry.
- Good to see you again.
- Good to see you, too.
- Gary.
- Good to see ya.
How ya doing?
- Yeah very well thank you.
- All well?
Good come on in.
Alex, you look good.
Jake Paul. Special.
Uh, what?
- Fan's birthday.
- Okay.
Can you do it?
- [DRock] We're
gonna go with it.
Conner, you
wanna be on this side?
That way we have three
cameras on that side.
That good?
- Two, three, one?
- Yes.
- Good.
Ready?
- Are you nervous?
- Very.
- You're nervous?
- Yeah.
- Why are you nervous?
- I always get nervous.
- I like that.
- I'm super not nervous.
(group laughing)
- [DRock] Alright ready?
And, action.
- Hey everybody this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 231 of
The #AskGaryVee Show and
it is a ridiculous show.
This is a ridiculous show.
- Okay so the first question is,
how safe would you play it
when faced with the decision
to quit your daytime job
to be an entrepreneur,
the only dream that
keeps you up at night?
- So Jake, ya know,
you're such a young guy.
You didn't go down the route.
Did you ever have a job
like maybe when you were 14?
- I had my own
landscaping company.
- So you were an
entrepreneur from the get.
- Yeah.
- There was no I'm
gonna work at Fat Burger
in Cleveland, Ohio.
- No.
- Okay.
- 'Cuz yeah.
- I don't know if
they have Fat Burgers
in Cleveland, Ohio but it's
just the first company.
Anyway, nonetheless, so
were your parents or
grandparents or anybody
in your family entrepreneurs?
- Not really, no.
My uncle was probably the
biggest entrepreneur but
didn't spend a ton of
time with him so I kinda
just had the natural
hustle for it I guess.
My dad was like yo you
shouldn't get a regular job
because you're not
going to learn anything.
If you have a landscaping
company you're gonna learn
how to negotiate.
- So your dad was
really pushing for it.
- Yeah.
He was like you're gonna
learn how to set the prices,
get customers,
get recurring business.
- Yep.
- So, ya know.
- Yeah, cool.
What's the question again?
- So how safe would you
play it when faced with
the decision to quit
your daytime job to be
an entrepreneur which
is the only thing
that keeps you up at night?
- You know, I mean look.
Anything that keeps you
up at night is something
that should be addressed.
And so if it's really
keeping you up at night,
like you're not sleeping,
you're stressed,
you're thinking that
I'm gonna have regret
my whole life.
I would take it very serious.
And I would play it
not safe at all.
If you're kinda full of shit,
and once in a while
you think about it.
And once in a blue moon
you think about it,
well then I would play it safe.
The punch line is this.
Way too many people are
playing it half pregnant.
You either do it or ya don't.
There is no in-betweens.
And that's the bottom line
when it comes to this.
This is binary.
You know I talk about
entrepreneurial tendencies
a ton. And that's fine.
Who am I to judge just because
I love entrepreneurship.
You do you.
But this question is silly,
because you don't need to
ask a question on a show
like this because if you
really couldn't breathe,
you would be doing it
and you wouldn't even
be worried about
my opinion on it.
Cool, let's move on.
- Working with Gary over
the past couple of months
has been such an
amazing experience
as a young entrepreneur
I don't have all the answers,
I'm making mistakes
all the time.
And so just by watching
his videos every single day
I'm able to learn and take
away little pieces of info
that help me build my company
and grow as an individual.
And I know he's grinding.
So I'm always trying to
keep up with his pace.
So yeah, love you Gary.
- Picture? Yeah.
- Should we get one together?
- Yeah let's get it.
- Yeah get it on tape
one of you two first.
- Okay.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
Good to see you buddy.
Good luck to you.
Bye guys, have a wonderful day.
Good luck on everything. Bye.
Ty.
- What's up?
- Let's go.
I saw Roman.
Yeah? Let's go.
- Roman, we're good to go.
Jake, 30 under 30 you
gonna vouch for him?
- Yeah.
- [Tyler] Cool.
- And push Mika.
I'm gonna be a little late
I'm trying to squeeze--
- [Tyler] Yeah. Exactly totally.
- Great to see you.
Great to see you.
How are you?
Matt, real pleasure.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- How've you been?
- I'm going great.
Good, man,
it's great to see you.
You too, a lot of different
experiences.
Good. Yeah. I'm sure.
It's great to see you, man.
Really good to see you.
Awesome.
- How's everything?
Things are good.
Yeah, busy.
- Yeah, I'm following.
- Good, a lot going on.
A lot going on.
- I like the new office.
- Have you seen some friends?
- Yeah I've been waiting for
them but he didn't want to--
- No worries.
- I would want to stop by.
- Please, dude.
You're family,
anywhere you wanna go.
So what's been going on?
What can we jam on?
- [Matt] Yeah, we've been
working on a product
called Shimmer.
- [Gary] Shimmer?
- Yeah, I'm not sure if you've
heard of it or anything.
Really what we're
building is a social
engagement platform.
The whole idea being that
social media is all about
content distribution obviously.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Very one to many.
- You're welcome.
It's good to see you.
Good luck, man.
- Pleasure.
- Yeah I really enjoyed this.
This was good, good luck.
I'm excited to play.
I'll give you some feedback.
I will, I definitely will.
And I'm genuinely,
I'm excited because I know
that you'll value--
Yeah, it's good.
I'll jam. I'll let ya know.
- [Matt] Appreciate it.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Good to see you.
- Have a good day.
- You too.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I'll definitely take it
'cause I'll actually want
to see how you're communicating.
- Cool, thanks so much.
- Take care of yourself, man.
Good luck.
- Thank you.
- We're gonna play pool soon.
- [DRock] Yes.
- What's request?
Is that like trying
to get Nash Grier
to sign up for your platform?
- Yeah.
- Where does it go?
- So you tap on it, you
got this nice little
message right there.
We've actually had to turn
of some because they're
too big for where
we're at right now.
- [Gary] Uh-huh.
There's some,
you'll like the roadmap.
We got a jam on that, November.
- Okay. I'm excited, man.
Good luck to you.
- Yeah, cheers.
- [James] Gary!
- What's up my man?
- [James] Pleasure,
how are ya?
- I'm well, how are you?
- I'm James, nice to meet you.
- James, real pleasure.
- [James] Hi,
I'm James Cole,
I've founded
H Influencer Collective.
We're a collective of
models, photographers,
videographers in
San Francisco, California
and all up and down the
California coastline.
This is what my company does.
So I wanna explain to you.
- Yeah.
So, James has been following
Gary territory here.
So, your dad, right?
He had a small wine shop,
- Yes.
- Knows his
customers super well,--
- Yes.
- It's bespoke,
he cares, yeah?
- Yes.
- This is in 1950.
- A local butcher or whatever.
- Yep.
- Now we're talking
2008 to 2012.
My dad worked for
Goldman Sachs for 30 years.
He got big, big, big, big, big
institutional, institutional,
global, global, global,
the bigger the better.
And all these brands,
I've heard you talk
about the big box store.
- Yes.
- This, that, and the other
thing, yeah?
Now the future, this is
what we're doing now.
You're either really little,
and you can reach big,
this is Gary delivering the zin
to the woman on December 23rd.
- Yep.
- This Wine Library, TV,
- So you're little, you're
caring about your customers,
you're reaching a big audience,
- Yes.
- You're content marketing,
- Email marketing, whatever.
Or you're a big, big,
big company Warby Parker,
and you feel small.
You care about your customers
through tech, right?
The problem is, all these
influencer marketing platforms
like Niche that sold
to Twitter or whatever,
they're playing this
game to your point.
They're cool with a sellout.
It's mass, mass, mass, mass,
- Agreed.
- With a shit ton
of influencers,
- Agreed.
- Yeah?
But the problem is
this is where it's at.
- 100%.
So now what?
- So you're building
a viable narrative.
- [Gary] Next.
- What?
- [Gary] Agreed.
Now what?
- What do you mean?
- [Gary] I completely
buy into that.
- Cool.
- [Gary] That will work.
- Yeah.
It has been working.
- [Gary] It's gonna work.
That's 100% gonna work.
- So, I wanna--
- [Gary] Then what?
- No, you can, you can--
- Okay I believe you.
I believe you.
- Okay, so what I've done,
So I came here today to talk
to Gary to get some advice
about scaling something that
shouldn't scale very well.
Which is leading
with your heart,
building a community
around authenticity
and really caring about the
content you're creating.
- The reason you're
probably attracted to me
is because I'm the
same thing as you.
- [James] Right.
- Guys like you and I,
the outcome is
predicated on the insanity.
This in un--
- [James] It doesn't scale,
Gary, it doesn't scale.
- This is un-build-able
by anybody else.
- [James] Yes.
- That's why nobody can beat us.
Because nobody's gonna
do what I'm gonna do.
Nobody is going to spend
20 hours a day working--
- [James] Yep.
- and giving a fuck so much
and using sensitivity
and caring as the weapon.
You've already won.
The 10 or 100 is predicated on
how much you're
gonna be willing to work.
Nothing else.
Because you can actually
manage more than 100.
Why wasn't it 50?
- [James] Totally.
- Right?
- [James] Yeah.
- So hearing that
the question becomes
how do we make the payoff?
If the payoff, and I get it man,
I love you for your honesty,
if the payoff is some
good enough number,
arbitrary to you, because that's
all that actually matters.
If you needed to do, like it'd
almost take you in a weird--
I'm actually very
intrigued by this.
This I like.
- [James] Cool.
- I almost think you have to
invent an arbitrary number
that gets your nut
off to the mission.
- [James] You mean to sell for.
- Do you wanna sell it?
- [James] Is that what
you're talking about?
Like my exit strategy--
- I thought--
No, or hit a revenue number.
- [James] Oh, yeah.
Profit is not really
what I'm focused on.
- Or whatever, in the
game that you're playing,
there's something that
makes your dad say, "huh".
And I don't know if you've
got a read on that number,
if you've made
up your own number,
if it's your number
first and then,
whether your dad says
"huh" or not,
you know that
was the right number,
but that needs to be the game.
You can win your game.
You can win.
But you need to
invent it right now,
and then you need to get there.
Do you understand?
- [James] Totally.
I don't know
what that number is,
I could work back
from the number,
I can also work with these
other people that I have,
they trust me.
- But again, when you
look at that model,
we can say the maximum
capacity of income
in that would be 29--
- Yeah 100k a month,
200k a month,--
- Right.
And then if we knew the
number needed to be,
if you do 40 million a year,
you could say, "I did it!"
- Yeah.
- Well then we just
work backwards
and realize the number of people
you need to manage is 747,
and then we're set.
What I know is this is set.
What I don't know is
you've got what I've got,
which is, you know
how to handle this.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
- And it'll be cool for you
to be challenging yourself
to think if you can.
Because it's different.
This is super
different than this.
- Yeah.
- And you might have it
in you, and you might not.
I don't know.
- Okay.
- But--
- Well I'm gonna take--
- By the way--
- The saturation and
then we'll find out.
- Or, you may wanna
try one right away--
- Dip my toe in the water.
- Yeah and see if
it's right for you.
- Okay.
- You see what I mean?
- [James] Yeah, totally.
Cool thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [James] Very helpful.
- Yeah, I understand.
- [James] It's cool, honestly,
I thought you would understand,
and then I prepped for this
watched hours and hours
and hours of your
shit and it was cool.
'Cause it was like,
same playbook, you know?
- It works.
Scaling up the un-scalable,
is the only good game.
- Yeah.
It's the only good game left.
It's the game of the future.
- For now.
- [James] Yeah.
- Until everybody figures out--
- You ended one
of my favorite talks
by saying "and it feels good",
and it does.
- And it feels good.
- Because these people--
- How, bro.
How you make your
money is more important
than how much you make.
- All of these people,
pizza boy, valet parking,
they're all chasing a dream
and until further notice
I hope I'm not Ponzi scheme-ing
the shit out of them,
but I'm giving them that dream.
I'm like, this guy--
- You know you're
not Ponzi scheme-ing,
the only reason you're hedging--
- I just don't know if
it's gonna work or not.
- You know it's gonna work.
What you're hedging against,
is you can never get
off the hamster wheel.
- [James] Okay, so can
I ask you this?
- Do you understand?
- [James] Yeah, I understand.
- Like that's, and by the
way, that's the punchline.
- [James] That's what I was
wondering about with you,
because there's no brakes.
- Ever.
- [James] Ever.
- 'Til the end.
And I knew that I can do it.
And I don't recommend
it for anybody.
- [James] Yeah.
Cool.
I had a really good
conversation with Gary,
we were really vibing,
he gave some really good advice,
sort of encouraged me to up
the intensity, go all in,
and never break
the authenticity promise.
Never sell out.
And stick it out.
Thanks Gary.
Appreciate it.
- You need to do me a favor.
You need to realize it's binary.
- [James] All in or all out.
- You'll lose otherwise.
- [James] Yeah.
- And then if you really,
really, wanna put yourself
up to the man that you wanna be,
you'll get depressed
that you sold out.
- I'll get the press
that I sold out?
- Depressed.
- Oh, depressed.
Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Totally.
- So before you put--
The moment that
was the most intense,
was the moment when I decided
and closed the door
on the hamster wheel
and realized it was
the rest of my life.
It's what nobody understands.
They're not gonna win.
The cynical game,
which is everybody,
they're gonna lose to me.
I'm gonna outlast them.
Got it?
- [James] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- [James] I do.
- And that is not
only for everybody,--
- [James] It's for no one.
- it's for no one.
And I never,
I never talk about it.
- [James] Yeah.
- Like I'm so glad that I get
to talk about it
with you right now.
Like that is a game I could
never ask anybody else,
I never fully ask anybody
to play my game,
because it is scary.
It's like shooting to Mars
and knowing you're
never coming back.
- [James] Mhmmm.
- So that is a big one, man.
And you need to make sure
before you close that door
that you're willing to go there.
And if not, that's okay,
and let's come up with
an alternative version.
But, when you
shut that fucking door,
there's only two outcomes.
You're right, or you're wrong.
And being wrong kind of
destroys your reputation
name to yourself for
the rest of your life.
- [James] I get it.
- I know you do.
- I felt it.
- [Gary] I know you do,
that's why I'm telling you.
- Cool.
- And he's been around a whole
lot with me for last year,
this is the first conversation
I've had like this.
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- Cool.
- [Gary] So I'm warning you.
- If you wanna do something
that doesn't scale,
you have to work harder
than everyone else.
And heart and soul throw
yourself into what you're doing.
And I think what Gary was saying
is I'm sort of at
a crossroads right now
and if I wanna commit
to doing something
that people say can't be done
which is to focus on
something that doesn't scale
in a world that is
so dominated by tech,
you gotta shut the door,
get on the hamster wheel
and never get off.
And he just wanted to make
sure I was ready for that.
Which I am.
- But on a very serious note,
it's all about
collecting the people,
that I win with,
and that I help win more than...
I genuinely believe,
and then, by the way,
this is all ego talking,
but I just know you
can win more with me
than without me.
(Roger giggles)
You know what I mean?
- [Roger] I hear ya.
- And that excites me
because it's a double win.
- [Roger] Right, right, right.
- I don't have
this talk very often
because it has to
feel like a double win,--
- [Roger] Right.
- because I feel like everybody,
everybody wins
when they're with me,--
- [Roger] For sure.
but I like when
I feel that I also win
because of that,
and that's rare.
And that's why
we're sitting here.
- [Roger] For sure, for sure.
I'll tell you this, listen,--
- Please.
- I'm committed to being here.
- I believe you.
- One thing is--
- That's actually like,
really like, important,--
- Right.
- but this talk is even
a different version of that.
- Well, that's what I mean,
and quite honestly,
when I say being here,
I mean being around you...
- Me. That's it,
that's it, that's it.
- [Roger] Yeah, exactly.
- And I think when you
take that mind shift,
then like, you look at it,
you're looking at it,
you know that whole picture,
where it's like,
it's two people kissing,
or it's like,--
- [DRock] The lamp.
- the lamp, or whatever,
yeah, the glass.
That's what I want.
- [Roger] Right, right.
I feel like I want to make
sure you're looking at the
silhouette or the people,
whatever (mumbles), you know.
- [Roger] Yeah.
- And that's when
it gets interesting.
That's what, and by the way,
you're not as bought in
as you think you are.
Let me explain why.
When I had this
conversation with (censored),
it was just like this.
But then, like,
as you get in deeper,
it gets better.
- [Roger] Right, cool,
with that...
- You know, like your first
couple months,
we had a good talk,
you know, but it,
it just gets better.
- [Roger] Totally.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Roger] Totally, absolutely,
absolutely.
- And so like,
when you start
making that commitment,
then you start having
conversations
with your family and your world,
about like, things like,
would I live anywhere?
- [Roger] Mhmmm.
What would I do?
What's important?
What do I love?
- [Roger] Right.
What do I care about?
Because I need Gary to know,
so he can reverse engineer
to create the things,
and vice-versa.
- [Roger] That's cool.
- I need to be willing to go
to Singapore for my whole life,
and I need to tell Gary
that I wanna live in a boat.
And one of those two
things could happen.
- [Roger] Right,
right, right, right.
- Do you understand?
- [Roger] Yeah like, I get it.
For sure, for sure.
So it's part of, yeah.
I mean, to your part
to get to the bigger picture.
- Just pot committed.
- [Roger] For sure.
- At all levels.
Not, I'm committed
to this place,
I'm gonna work there.
- [Roger] Right, right.
- So, it's just very different.
- [Roger] And it's
less that for me.
And I want you to
know that as well.
- Okay.
- [Roger] For me, having
been in multiple places--
- But you know what else,
I have empathy, it is still
early
and we've had
limited interaction.
- [Roger] Totally.
- So that's why
I called this meeting,
'cause I keep,
I'm adding blocks.
- [Roger] Yeah, let's
keep doing more of that.
- We will.
- [Roger] Quite honestly,
I'll do more of that.
- It's just about humility
when you have to take the L.
- [Roger] It's interesting,
you know what's funny is,
taking an L is an art.
Not an art, but,
you gotta like, it's a thing.
- It's an art, or whatever
you wanna define--
You have to know
how to take an L.
- Yeah. You got to
be able to do it,
and keep it moving.
Like, getting crippled
by Ls is a problem,
it happens to a lot of people.
- I love Ls.
- I do too.
I know, I've seen you,
you've done some good.
Listen, when they light
the fire on your ass,
it's no way, it's--
- I love Ls.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I love the
I told you so, so much.
'Cause I know what I am.
(Roger laughs)
You know what I mean?
Cool, man,
I'm glad we got to talk.
- All right, man.
- All right,
have a good weekend.
- All right, good luck to
your Jets this weekend.
- Ah, that's a--
- Giants though, man.
Giants are like, agh!
- It's over, yeah Giants suck.
- Although, I think,
you know what?
I think we're
appropriately two and two.
I would say that.
- Nah, it should be oh-and-four.
(Roger laughs)
The Saints game's ludicrous.
- [Tyler] You want to do
Shamika from here or from the
car?
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Tyler] You want to do
Shamika from here or the car?
- [Gary] From the car, I think.
(laughing)
All right, I'm heading out,
and cutting into...
Here's a good one for you guys,
I've been cutting
my Fridays a lot earlier
to spend more family time.
It's actually a
little bit later for me.
You can flash the time.
It's just a new
switch I've made.
But fuck, man,
did we cram a
ton of all-time shit
into this day.
I was on a fuckin'--
- [DRock] There was a lot today.